افاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق عدد من
الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المحاذيه للقطاع من جهه اقاله الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان القبه الحديديه اعترضت خمسه
صواريخ اطلقت من قطاع غزه باتجاه بلدات
اسرائيليه متاخمه للحدود مع القطاع بينما
سقط اخر بمنطقه مفتوحه وكانت صفارات
الانذار قد دوت في عسقلان وسيديرود في
منطقه غلاف غزه
المزيد من التفاصيل مع مراسل الجزيره وائل
الدحدوح الذي ينضم الينا الان من غزه اهلا
بك وائل ما الذي حدث
كل الذي حدث يستند اولا الى يعني شيئين
الاول هو الشهود الاعيان الذين سمعوا
اطلاق او اصوات انفجارات تشبه اصوات اطلاق
الصواريخ انطلاقا من قطاع غزه والشيء
الاهم هو هو الروايه الاسرائيليه التي
تحدثت عن اطلاق نحو سته صواريخ انطلاقا من
قطاع غزه باتجاه منطقه الغلاف ومنطقه
عسقلان منطقه الغلاف هي التي تقع الى حدود
منطقه عسقلان على امتداد السياج الفاصل مع
قطاع غزه السواء في الشمال او في شرق قطاع
غزه لكن هذه المره يعني ربما تجاوزت هذه
الصواريخ قليلا
كما يبدو تستهدف كانت مطلقه باتجاه منطقه
عسقلان كما اعلن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي الجيش تحدث عن اعتراض من قبل
القبه الحديديه لخمسه من الصواريخ حسب
روايه الجيش في حين
سقط الصاروخ السادس في منطقه مفتوحه دون
وقوع اصابات حسب مصادر الجيش الاسرائيلي
او حسب المتحدث باسم باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي حتى الان فلسطينيا
ليس هناك بيان صدر من اي جهه من الجهات او
الفصائل الفلسطينيه يتبنى اطلاق الصواريخ
وهي هذه الحاله تنطبق على معظم الحالات
التي تطلق فيها صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
منطقه الغلاف في اطار يعني الفعل ورد
الفعل في اطار اطلاق الصواريخ عندما تكون
هناك اعتداءات من هذا النوع الذي حصل في
منطقه نابلس نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
ولكن في كل الاحوال كانت التوقعات عاليه
جدا بان تعمد احدى الفصائل الفلسطينيه على
اطلاق صواريخ ردا على هذه المجزره كما
وصفت لان معظم التصريحات التي صدرت في
البيانات عن كل الفصائل الفلسطينيه كانت
تؤكد بان الفصائل ذاهبه الى الرد وان كان
هذا الرد الذي جاء ان اقتصر على هذا النحو
فانه التزاما كما يبدو بالقواعد المتعارف
عليها وان تجاوزت قليلا في صاروخ واحد على
الاقل واذا دحدوح مراسل الجزيره من غزه
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه الاضاحات